más de 100 líderes se reúnen
virtualmente para el primer encuentro de
este tipo esta cumbre de países que se
comprometen con el progreso democrático
a pesar de que quedan dudas sobre que
tanta responsabilidad en la ejecución de
estas metas tengan los mandatarios
presentes al respecto la casa blanca
dijo que estaba trabajando con el
congreso para proporcionar
424,4 millones de dólares en un nuevo
proyecto para impulsar la democracia en
todo el mundo incluyendo el apoyo a
medios de comunicación
independientes por su parte la
secretaria del tesoro janet yellen
afirmó que está tomando medidas contra
el lavado de dinero las finanzas
ilícitas y la evasión de impuestos
porque eeuu no puede ser dice ella una
voz creíble para un gobierno libre y
justo en el extranjero que al mismo
tiempo permite que los ricos infrinjan
leyes con impunidad finalmente el
presidente joe biden dijo que la
democracia no ocurre por accidente y que
se tiene que renovar con cada generación
hay que mencionar que los líderes de
china y rúsia no fueron invitados y el
portavoz del ministerio de asuntos
exteriores chino dijo que la invitación
a taiwán se muestra de que estados
unidos está usando esta cumbre por la
democracia como una herramienta para
avanzar con sus objetivos geopolíticos